Peter your IMDB says you were born and
grew up in Texas yeah grew up in Texas
right across the river from Oklahoma in
a town called Denison no memories of it
we transferred that when I was 18 months
old headed up to at the time what might
as well have been Mars to us it was a
New Hampshire much different so that's
where I spent my golden years grew up
there loved it eventually moved to
Colorado and have been progressively
heading out west ever since now here I
am in Los Angeles did you go to film
school I did I went to the University of
Colorado in Boulder wonderful school a
bit avant-garde definitely an emphasis
on film Theory documentary not so much
the Hollywood studio system but
nonetheless it was a good school very
fine professors many of whom I'm still
in touch with today but as soon as I
graduated I knew the kind of filmmaking
I wanted to do so I went right down the
road
right out here and you've done mostly
horror films I know you said you you
don't want to be just totally put in
that one category but was that your plan
no no it wasn't my plan my first couple
of films actually when I want it when I
came out to LA I needed a few years to
put the pieces in place and start making
movies and my first couple films were
dramas there was a thriller in there but
it was not at all or I made a few of
those and decided to in a sense lighten
it up a little bit to have some fun and
go into kind of a fun John type of
picture and I have a soft spot for
horror I've always loved horror I always
will love horror and it was not until my
third or fourth picture and I believe
that I delved into that genre and then I
rolled off a number in a row and those
started to pick up steam and I started
to get branded as a horror film maker
and which I'll take I enjoy it but no
I've delved into a number of genres and
I imagine I'll continue to in years come
when you were at film school you said it
was a bit avant-garde so
were they because I mean because they
were in Colorado did they not sort of
know that Hollywood kind of has its own
set of rules some of which are fantastic
and some of which are terribly unethical
oh they are not too aware of the type of
business I mean it certainly was the
antithesis to going to say USC where you
are trained as certainly the master's
program where they train you for the
industry and what type of pictures
they're looking to make out there and
how to break into the industry plus
you're out there in Los Angeles metro
and you're meeting these contacts I can
get you right into the business see you
was more about teaching you from a
grassroots standpoint just the love of
film itself again a lot of it was
documentary or experimental or
independent I guess would be a better
word to wrap up all of it they weren't
so interested in training you to go out
there and make the neck bottom to make
the next blockbuster wasn't on the radar
at all they wanted to teach you about
the classics the silent period and 40s
50s 60s all the great film movements in
all the different countries which was an
invaluable education I loved it I think
if I'm going to be in this industry and
to make film I want to understand where
it started where it bloomed and where
it's evolved and all those kind of
things so that was really their focus
not so much turning you into the next
Spielberg that would have been the last
thing on their mind you know but but it
taught me a lot of important things in
terms of what kind of filmmaker I wanted
to be what kind of stories I wanted to
tell and then I took that and when I
came out to Los Angeles I you know let
that evolve on its own but I think it
probably took an extra couple of steps
whereas if you go to a certain other
school or a certain program out here
from day one they're teaching you I
would think how to get into the studio
system and survive and in this city in
the industry
it's just apples and oranges why do you
think Colorado being I mean this may
sound so cliche but much more grounded
just just sort of by I think the
location probably has something to do
with it plus Boulder is known for being
Boulder you know that's really nice yeah
it's gorgeous and it really was it was a
strong film school by and large every
film program is going to be a little bit
different you should know what kind of
film program it's going to be obviously
that can determine what kind of track
you're taking in the next step in your
career you know USC is great for people
looking to come out to make films in
California but then that might not be
the best choice for everybody there's a
lot of different types of stories to
tell and a lot of different types of
filmmakers so you know you should know
kind of what their specialties are what
their strengths are what the weaknesses
are Boulder
it's just apples and oranges to other
film programs not better or worse it was
its own kind of unique entity and I
loved it that's great yeah sounds really
nice
yes having been out here several years
do you think that the film and
television industry is fair um I think
fair in the sense that like everything
in life it's it's it's a battle to stand
out fair or not I think whatever things
that have been obstacles or challenges
fair or whatnot nowadays has been around
for a long time in terms of how extreme
it is I think it might go up and down
through the years but regardless of what
the circumstances are it's always going
to be a scrap to put your career
together and to move forward I to me the
biggest challenge of being out here
isn't really what's been what's fair not
fair it's been access these days
especially because everyone can purchase
gear everyone can edit gear everyone can
bring together crews and make their own
films which is great by the way but it
also means that you're up against
millions of aspiring filmmakers and so
it's become it was ever so difficult
before but it's become even more so now
to stand out from the ocean of other
people you know there's really no way to
directx as to managers or to agents
entertainment attorneys for cold
submissions they don't even take a look
at him anymore and have it for several
years and I think you couldn't
necessarily just walk up to him in years
past but there were certain ways you
could kind of skirt around and get
through to them that you don't have now
you really these days have to write a
script that is blazing hot or make a
film that in its own way goes viral
whether that's online or through the
festival circuit to even have a shot and
it's got to be seen by the right people
on the right day and without that you're
in for an uphill battle it's just the
reality of being out here with so many
filmmakers that to me is is the biggest
challenge more so than what I would
consider fair or not fair because
they're gonna find that in any industry
okay interesting so so you don't have to
brand it as unfair it's just that it's
it's so crowded that it creates its own
rules maybe yeah since I would say it
I'm so focused on how to stand out and
to keep honing my craft and make the
best films I can I'm like the best
scripts I can and getting them into the
hands the right people that I don't have
time to think about what's fair not fair
that's just kind of something I you know
table for later so I haven't really put
that much thought into it these days of
course you can go online or read
headlines and I'm sure there's fair and
unfair things left right and center but
I just haven't had time to focus on it
I've been way too focused on just trying
to kind of get ahead one step at a time
since you'd love horror even though I
know you want to do other films and
you've done drama in the past I think I
read something where you put that horror
doesn't have to be gruesome to be good
and to be to effectively scare the
audience can you touch on that yeah I
you know and I say this with respect to
everyone because everyone enjoy
something different and I can certainly
respect that for me personally I was
always a fan of the horror films of
yesteryear the universal classics and so
on and so forth
films that relied on atmosphere and
drama and conflict and
those type of things to really bring out
a different kind of scare
they didn't need a throw a cat from
around a corner and they didn't need to
tear someone's face off it was a kind of
it was the kind of horror that would
really get under your skin or maybe it
wouldn't hit you until the next day
something that was you know just kind of
marrow deep it would just kind of get
inside you and it was all about the
story that trend in Hollywood in another
place it kind of goes back and forth
there was a time in the early 2000s when
what used to be considered extreme
horror became mainstream in terms of
violence and things like that you had
the hostels coming out you had saw
coming on that became very popular
really disturbing realistic violence
again to each their own if that's your
thing no problem but wasn't for me so I
was seeing them for many of us going
well gee I mean it's horror really where
I want to be right now maybe I need to
explore some of the genres and whatever
but you know the fact is the world over
horror is always being made in different
ways surprising ways and right when I
was at my low point of like maybe I
should start making some drama as I'll
just take a break from horror for a bit
I saw a movie called Let The Right One
In which you may have heard of out of
Sweden and I went bah my kind of horror
is still around I think was just a
beautiful horror film and a strong drama
and just a really interesting movie that
although it did have violence it wasn't
dependent upon it it was relying on
different variables to unsettle you and
and to scare you and so I realize I'm
gonna be okay there's still films out
there that that are being made that I
like and lets me know that I should
stick into this genre just keep making
my own my own thing but wrapping around
the original question I I certainly
don't think you need gore or extreme
language or extreme what-have-yous to
make a great horror picture I think
there's a lot of different ways to do it
and you should do it however you enjoy
it the most and there's gonna be an
audience for it I'm trying to think I
mean even the Exorcist it has some core
you know gore and you know I'm not even
talking about the
where she throws up but if you take that
and that was so scary to me back in the
day deeply because it was the music and
the mystery or just this sort of just
unknown you know and we end but yeah and
then you take what's today and they need
to have so many kills per whatever a
minute to keep the audience yeah yeah
well I you know I'm sure there were
horror films even back in the day that
were considered more commercial or more
extreme or whatever it may be but you
know one of the things I love about
Korres it's always evolving it's always
surprising you and there's always a new
bold vision that's going to come from
left field that will influence the next
ten years of what horror is going to be
at one point it was extreme violence at
one point you know what came to be known
as torture porn there was found footage
and there and who knows how many
subgenres these days there is a zombie
sub-genre and so on and so forth it's
always evolving and in that sense
there's always an opportunity for you to
be the guy that comes up with something
new and really exciting that will
surprise the world and just when you
think god what other stories are there
to tell we've told every story that one
can possibly tell you'll go and you'll
see a film you're just like wow why
didn't I think of that
something simplistic and genius all at
the same time something scary in a new
way something that takes his genre and
turns it on its head you know it's a
great Jean WA and I'm up and excited to
see what what the next filmmaker is
gonna bring us even with hereditary
there were definitely several scenes
that were like okay I can't see this but
the main crux of it was this like family
story and within that was was there was
a lot of like fear around certain things
and I thought that they did that
effectively you know III was on the edge
of my seat yes there were parts where I
just didn't want to see them but for the
most part I was actually incredibly
impressed yeah I I have a lot of
admiration for those type of filmmakers
who are able to tell a story that wasn't
designed to be super marketable or to
hit all the bullet points
because you know I'm always trying to
make a living trying to get more
projects up and running and one of the
challenges I loft you'll run into is
this is really cool this is a great
concept that you've come up with but I
don't know how to sell it if you want to
get something done with us come back to
us with something that hits all the
marketing keynotes gave us something
that hits all the beats that everyone's
seen before and you're like well you
know I do want to get a movie made and
I'd love to sure you know do business
but it makes it challenging I guess to
make something that's different and
unique and doesn't follow all the rules
or makes up some of its own rules so but
where there's a will there's a way so
when you find movies like that someone
got made for the babadook or any one of
another which is another one just movies
were like they're almost the antithesis
of what one would usually consider a
marketable genre picture because they're
so different and they're so kind of slow
burns and just kind of doing it their
own way you know I would love to do a
project like that so whenever I see
someone do it it it's very exciting for
me and I commend him a lot for because
that's that's something that I aspire to
do is as well in the years end so when
you don't have a lot of money to make a
film is it almost where you're making a
better story in some sense I think I
read something where you said that those
are actually some of the better stories
that you've created as always it depends
who you ask with me because for so many
years I didn't have very much money and
I would make movies with whatever I had
I've made films for 200 bucks 500
dollars a thousand and yes because you
were forced to think economically you
couldn't afford to bring in all the best
gear all the best lights you couldn't
afford cranes you couldn't afford
multiple takes you'd had to do
everything in a day so it would force
you to really dig into a scene and go
this is how I want to tell this scene
and so for the most part maybe not every
time but for the most part that would I
would find force me to shoot a scene and
then I watched the complete picture and
it would come out stronger than I think
if I had had 25 different
in 15 different angles and all the time
and all the money in the world so it's
been a focusing agent for me that being
said you know on any one of those if I'd
had the opportunity to have more money
and more coverage I probably would have
gladly take it oh sure but no I think
you know anytime you can dive into a
scene and tell it well without all the
tricks up your sleeve
that's always a good sign you know
everything if you do happen to have more
time and more money more crew and all
that and all the goodies great use it
have fun with it do things you wouldn't
be able to do otherwise but I think you
know any good script and a good story
should be should be told and have the
ability to be told with a camera and two
guys right there you know what I mean
like it should almost tell itself all
you're doing is strengthening it and
bringing it to life but you really
shouldn't need everything to tell it for
you would you ever try to get a producer
to work on your phone for free I
wouldn't have okay you know once I got
into the feature world the rules were a
little different that scenario has come
up actually but it's a little trickier
and things can change in the short film
world all bets are off it's whatever you
can do to get the film made I once I had
built up a body of work I'd done five
six seven short films and I'd started to
brand myself and try to get my work out
there and get some pressed articles I
mean whatever I would use that to sell
myself to producers or aspiring
producers anyone who could help me I
would bring in so long is if there was a
way I can help them so a lot of these
people were people who just wanted to be
involved in films they may not have a
lot of experience but they had some
funding and I'd say listen I'm not gonna
take your money I turned down a lot of
students and a lot of young people but
if they could afford it I'd take it $200
I'd give him some producing credits I
would ask them to come to set I would
teach them some things on the job let
him be involved and of course do the
premiere and all that stuff but I was
really never good at wanting to simply
take people's money but I would always
try to give them something
especially those that were really
volunteering their time in their efforts
weren't being paid a thing I wanted it
to be something that everyone was
growing in in one way or another whether
it was experience or film currency
meaning IMDB credits and press something
that they could use for themselves but
absolutely there were many times I was
like listen I could use your help here
can't afford to pay up but I won't take
up a week your time come out help me for
a day help me for two days I would make
it manageable so it was something that
they could do and when I was younger
there were people who'd asked me listen
I've got this feature or short film
whatever whatever it may be
could you come out and help for free
it's for three weeks in Georgia I can't
you know can't do it so I would whenever
I would put people in that position I
would make sure it was something that
was reasonable and and make the best of
it and by and large it was always a
great experience from from both ends you
have how many features that you're
either working on now or I have half a
dozen in various forms of development
but I have one in post-production I'm
sorry I had wrapped up post-production
that's locking up distribution right
down oh great and then I have one escape
room which came out in 2017 which was my
debut feature okay and so and once I
made the jump from shorts to features
with escape room there was at least from
time being no looking back I said I'm
not getting any younger
I got to focus full-time on features now
and make it go of it because one of the
main reasons I did those shorts for all
those years and I did 17:18 shorts
whatever was had a blast was to prepare
myself for the feature world to
challenge myself and to put myself
through trial by fire in every way I
could think of working with kids working
at night working with you know in sambal
cast working with no lights anything I
could think of I would write into a
script and challenge myself to prepare
for the feature world and once escape
room came out
things started to pick up so my focus
has been on that ever since and and I'm
excited for those to come out and I went
a lot more to come out I was one things
to be busier I think you said too that
you didn't want to take on massive
amounts of debt and I think that's
really smart because so many people do
and then they end up tapping out and
then they can't yeah and then they can't
answer their phone and they can't you
know what I'm saying and that's no way
to live and mutsu pay medical bills it's
one thing but to make a movie it's like
this shouldn't be where now this is
gonna be this like noose that I'm know
and that again comes down to who you ask
is I know a lot of filmmakers who went
all-in maxed out credit cards and they
made it that's true I I am but by and
large it's a very dangerous move that I
personally would never do so I got lucky
with a scape room i I sold that script
some people and and it got financed
nothing to do with my own personal
credit but yeah to me you know and
especially since I have kids but many
filmmakers do I just that's a road I
will never go down I will always go out
there push my scripts out pitch them and
so on and so forth through a variety of
avenues but I can never imagine maxing
everything out because everything in the
film business is a gamble and usually
it's a gamble that's stacked against you
that's just the way the business is
there's so many people vying for X
amount of money and X amount of
positions and X amount of slate
positions if you will companies looking
for films that it's just really hard so
to put all your marbles in especially if
you're not 100% certain that you're
ready to make a movie that's gonna
really make a difference and really gets
old really quick you know it's a gamble
I won't sit here and say don't do it
because some people are gonna do what
they're gonna do and it'll pay off but
for me you know it's not a risk I'm
gonna take yeah I mean if you if you
don't have kids okay then you know a lot
of things yeah and some people are just
they believe that strongly in their
concept and they are able to execute it
I have seen times when people go all-in
and they've got all the passion they've
got all the right
ingredients inside to have made that
move they believe in themselves they
work hard they sacrifice for it and they
make a movie you know that just doesn't
work you know it just wasn't a movie
that was you know digestible to
distributors it wasn't something they
wanted to pick up and so they get their
film made they made it that's half the
battle but then they could never sell it
so they never made any money back off of
it and so this is a filament kind of
sits on a shelf and it's never really
seen by the public unless they put it on
YouTube where maybe they find some way
to self distribute which is possible but
you know again it's all part of the same
bubble it's a risk you know and in the
film business everything's a risk so it
comes down to the individual what do you
want to risk and and when do you want to
risk it and for me I just tend to be on
the more conservative side of that even
if it means it's gonna take me longer to
reach a certain goal I'll go the slower
route I'll play it safe sure so then I'm
sorry you did you you paid the producers
or they were the thing for the feature
yeah
the feature my script for ask a permit
list
it was producer found it he loved it he
introduced it to some other people some
middlemen who brought it to a production
company and they financed it then once
they agreed to do the project they had
the money in place and I think 24 or 48
hours really quick and after that it
just snowballed really fast they were
shooting like within a month and so on
and so forth
but no someone else someone else paid
for that you know and for that movie in
the one after that it was a sub million
dollar movie you're not talking to
studio level 50 million dollar movies
here these are smaller movies and when
you're talking about a million dollars
or under you're talking private
investors it's you know you're talking
about generally some really rich people
we want to make movies and so we got
lucky with escape room the producers had
an investor great guy who really wanted
to be involved and it's you know
financing came entirely through him and
I think he's actually financed several
more pictures through that particular
company since then but you know that's
just how that movie came together every
movie is its own story in terms of
finance
see how it comes together what
challenges there are but certainly with
the money you know it's it's always a an
interesting process how many years did
you work on just short films I did short
films in college of course so that was
going back to well I'll put it this way
I've been making short films since I was
a kid with the old block camcorder that
had to be plugged into the walls but if
we're talking about real films with
crews you know professional or at least
semi-professional I think my first was
in 99 or 2000 I took about a four year
break once I moved to Los Angeles didn't
know anybody didn't have any money so I
needed to put some pieces together and
once I did that that probably was 2005
and I think my last short film to date
at least would have been a fun little
crime action film called sweet madness
which I believe was 2015 so good solid
ten years of just non-student and we're
not talking student films or kid films
like me going out there pulling in
investors and producers pulling the crew
together and just getting it done
there's probably good solid ten eleven
years so that four years that you came
here and you weren't making films what
was that like cuz you you'd planned
making films since you were a kid go to
film school in a really cool town and
and then you come here and essentially
you probably feel like oh wow now I'm
gonna be living what I set out to do
well reality hits as much as I love the
film school again it didn't prepare you
to go into this industry not Los Angeles
I came out in a sense cold turkey
I'd been taught how to load some mags
and I wrote like a short film script of
my senior film class but I didn't know
how to pull a crew together I didn't
know how to produce I didn't know about
permits I didn't know anything about any
of it I knew I had to learn it though I
also didn't have any money I had to get
a job pretty soon you find yourself
working a job or two
and I tried I was doing that I got some
internships on the side to try to meet
people figure out how the business
worked I eventually got a job at a
literary agency representing writers and
directors and so on and so forth to
learn that side of the business I
started to put together my long term
plan at that point I wanted to know who
was who in the town I wanted to know how
contracts worked what was fair what
wasn't fair I wanted to learn how these
people got representation what it took
and it just took time to get these
things in place and while I was doing
these jobs I had access to no gear I
didn't have money to pay for gear I
didn't know people to ask they'd come in
to volunteer
I had no press no brand to sell myself
to get people to want to work with me
for nothing so it took a number of years
to get to a place where I was like okay
I am as close as I'm going to be I mean
I could wait another 10 years but I'm as
close as I'm going to be to having the
ability to do my first post-college film
and that was around 2005 I just
eventually just pulled the trigger I
said I'm doing it I'll figure out the
rest at some point you just got to go
with it I mean so I did I made that film
for about seven or eight thousand
dollars that was the last film I shot on
actual film after that everything went
digital and it saved me a tremendous
amount of money but yeah I that's
something that that film students and
everything canons should be aware of in
terms of of me I just didn't know any
better I went to a film school that
taught me some amazing things about the
history of film and I'm so glad I
learned it but I came out here like a
baby I didn't know anybody didn't know
anything and had to learn everything on
my own from the ground up which has
proved beneficial to me in the long run
but at first it was challenging
you just had to find your way and just
go with it you know with film you could
read a million books but there's no
simple a twosie about how to make it or
how to be a producer or director or
writer so I kind of did it the only way
I knew how I learned how on set and
whatever mistakes I made I learned from
them
and didn't do them again but it it's and
everyone's got their own road
was mine so yeah I had that little 4
year pause and once that pause ended
I've been pumping out films ever since
were you working at the literary agency
the entire four years
no what ended up I will know I worked at
the literary agency for about a year and
a half I interned at Paramount interned
for some other producers in town I
worked at why don't you remember the
name of I worked at the mall
I worked at restaurants I just worked
you got to make your money oh sure but
that taught me early on one of the most
important lessons which for me I always
knew what I wanted to do there was no
doubt about it and I was prepared for it
to be an uphill battle for the rest of
my life and it has been I mean being a
filmmaker is hard in all the best ways
to me I think everything you really love
and care about it's hard you know it
takes a lot of effort and filmmaking
certainly requires a lot of effort but
as I've been out here in Los Angeles
steadily working away and putting my
pieces in place and kind of figuring out
okay where is this gonna lead me in five
years versus ten years like where do I
want to go and how am I gonna get there
it took a while for me to figure out
exactly what I needed to do but
throughout that journey I saw a lot of
people come out wanting to do the same
they wouldn't make it very long and one
of the most common traits I saw and the
people who didn't make it very long were
those who I don't think fully
appreciated how hard filmmaking is I
think they loved film I don't think they
loved filmmaking and it's an important
difference I think that if you come out
to this town with stars in your eyes and
some of these things I've written about
before which you might have read some of
my articles but I think if you come out
to LA to be a filmmaker and kind of the
preeminent thought you have is fame and
fortune I think that's a fine motivation
to have but if it's your primary
motivation I think it's going to be
disappointing for you because the odds
are of you making it big are slim to
none
I think for me it for most others if you
can sit there and tell yourself that I
will I I would do this for free the rest
of my life working side jobs never gonna
make a lot of money I'm not gonna have a
big house in Beverly Hills I'm not gonna
you know mingle with the Stars
if you can tell yourself that I would be
happy just making stories small films
that maybe will go to some festivals but
that's about it
and you're okay with that as let's say a
worst case scenario that's all you're
ever gonna do and you're okay with that
I think you're on your way that's a very
good place to start if you do achieve
more and you aspire for more I think
that's perfectly fine but to me that's
always been icing on the cake it'll be a
bonus but I think it's your core you
really need to love the process because
it's it's a challenging one and it's not
for everybody did you see anything that
was eye-opening by working with these
writers at the literary agency I mean I
don't know how close she actually got to
the writers maybe you didn't get that
close to them but just in terms of
seeing the ones that because I know
there's writers that are frustrated with
the you know whether they're novelist or
whatever and it's not what they thought
and they have well sure editors can
totally controlling their book and it's
not you know so there's a lot of
similarities I learned a lot of things
working at the agency I think in terms
of your question the most important
thing I took out of it from a strictly
writing and directing standpoint is that
the fight never ends because it is very
very hard to get representation from a
manager standpoint but certainly from an
agency standpoint you pretty much have
to be a moneymaker to get attention from
an agency sometimes they'll take on
someone who want a big festival because
they believe in them and they see them
as a good investment about what would
happen often is if an agent has say 30
clients these are all people who made it
they're talented people they've broken
through from that ocean of people even
then you know maybe the top five clients
get time with the agents and one else
gets ignored for weeks at a time because
they're not the big money they're not
making the big a-list movies with the
hot new director
established director they you know made
something that won a big festival tell
you riot or whatever it may be or
they're a journey man who's made some
movies that have been successful here
and there but anyways they're people
who've made movies many of which have
been released theatrically they've
they've made it they're still fighting
it's gonna be a scrap and Lester
Spielberg one of these upper upper
echelon people it's always gonna be a
script and I that was something I
learned early on I said oh so these guys
they made I mean they fought the fight
and they emerged from five hundred
thousand other aspiring filmmakers and
they made it and they're still like I
need a job like get get me into a room
let me pitch someone pitch my script and
whatever it is so that was interesting
to me and I think both enlightening and
I I think advantageous because again I
was already kind of prepared but it
prepared me even more so to be okay with
it to be okay
to never reach a point where I go okay
boy projects are being thrown in my lap
left to right is great that even after
after a and Here I am with escape room
came out theatrically world wide opened
up number one in the UK so it did pretty
good it was a small movie but did pretty
good
I didn't have agencies call me no
management companies called me no
entertain attorneys called me I'm still
securing my own deals and I'm getting
more and more and better and better
deals but it's not like it opened the
floodgates so there's never like a door
you open where it just it's easy from
here on out and I think a lot of people
would be surprised to hear that
especially filmmakers escape room is a
movie that you wrote is that right did
you also direct it I did I had written
several spec screenplays that were very
ambitious very my you know my hereditary
or my Baba Dook my Let The Right One In
something bold and different and
atmospheric and so on and a lot of my
specs would get optioned but not
financed it always scared the financers
thing one
something you can pitch in one line
something that can easily be marketed in
one job maybe two so I said okay well
I'm getting older here I need to write
something for the first time in my life
I need to write something for them
something that they're looking for
something with all the bullet points or
all the marketing you know keys I said
so my game will be what can I write for
them that I'm still proud of something
that walks the line that's something for
them and something for me also so I you
know they like something that's got a
strong hook that's high concept that can
be produced easily all these things so I
had been to an escape room and saw that
it was kind of blowing up and getting
more and more popular I said okay well
I'm gonna form a story around that long
story short I found an angles that I
wanted to tell that story I wrote it
very quickly sold it very quickly first
script I ever sold that got financed
immediately because it hit all their
points I went maybe there's something
learn from this and it was again it was
off to the races what they financed it
it moved very quickly but my game since
then has been to balance writing I'll
say for them but writing what's really
marketable versus maybe some other types
of stories that I really want to tell
also I try to oscillate and kind of go
between them a little bit without going
too far into any it's it's a fine dance
that I'm still learning and will
continue to learn a little bit more but
it's interesting because there's a lot
of super talented writers I've seen out
there who've never had a single script
financed even optioned because they have
written these bold screenplays that you
know doesn't isn't a great fit for say a
broad audience or just a just a very key
demographic that can be sold to
investors and investors like safe bets
like anybody else so you know God bless
and I hope they get financed because
some of these scripts are fantastic
scripts but if you are a new script
writer and you are looking to be like
gosh I want to get a do anything to get
option that one time let me get optioned
it is something worth considering keep
fighting the good fight but you know
if you're gonna be in the business of
filmmaking there is a business aspect to
it and that includes marketable material
what's currently trending right now it's
you know female-driven grounded
thrillers or IP content whatever it is
but keep your finger on the pulse and at
times give them what they want but
inject enough of yourself into it that
it's something you can be really proud
of so what was the process like once you
finished writing escape room how are you
knowing where to send it out I mean
that's that's really fascinating so you
go to this escape room you go oh okay
this is cool I've been to one it's
really neat it's kind of cool to hear
with strangers like trying to figure
something out and there's just a lot of
fun to it but you you go okay so I've
got a hit on these beats great okay so
you finish it probably have it maybe one
or two people look at it I don't know
I'm just assuming I may have had my
younger sister Aubrey read it okay but
not many what some people will do and
listen I haven't done everything the way
some real professional other
screenwriters would do some guys there's
certain routes you might go when you
take it to prestigious breakdown
services and they cover it and they go
this is amazing or this is great but you
really need to fix X Y and C there's a
number of things you can do that are
legitimate ways to get it properly
prepared early on I just never did I
never did that I certainly not with
escape room I have with some of my
scripts since then and it's been
actually pretty valuable and getting
them optioned but with a scape room I
just wrote it for as simple as it was I
was like I don't need to take the time
or the money to get someone professional
to cover it I know what it is I wrote it
for the people I know what they want
this is enough this is what it is and
and it turned out it was in terms of how
I got it out for people to see there's
different routes I've learned along the
way for many years I literally put
scripts out on God Craigslist
online free sites Craigslist which might
waste your time 99% of the time in what
section screenwriters I believe local
writers they've changed since escape
since that one got done now it's a paid
site and I've adjusted some of the rules
a little bit so I don't know if you can
do it anymore but and I went on
Craigslist to hire crew I used it for
years both sure anyways I put scripts
out there for years nothing but the
right guy saw it on the right day on
Craigslist on Craigslist and said let's
hop on the phone and we hopped on the
phone conversation went well met in
person conversation went well sold it
you still have the post did you do like
a screen shot no I don't have to pose
I'm still in touch with the guy a long
time and other guys I have another
picture that's coming together now I I
can't divulge details or keeping it all
under wraps but I'm hoping it's my
game-changer it's going at an a-list
level far bigger budget than anything
I've ever done that the seedling of that
deal began through I think LinkedIn
some guy the right guy on the right day
saw post of mine or saw my page and went
hey do you got anything and I said sure
and I pitched him a bunch of concepts he
picked one or two or whatever I sent it
to him he goes okay this is cool let me
read this script and usually they'll say
that you'll hear from him never again or
six weeks down the road he called me two
hours later and said I want it I know
exactly what I'm taking it to and it was
off to the races
so these sites that don't cost any money
that's another thing I picked up through
my years is it takes a lot of time but
get yourself out there Craigslist
LinkedIn Instagram Facebook Twitter
build yourself a brand and and network
my first several years making short
films I was so busy making films I never
networked never marketed the films
barely ever well I made posters but I
didn't do a whole lot with him I've
changed my ways
since then I've definitely focused
certainly when I was ready to jump into
the feature world I started reaching out
to anyone and everyone I could that I
knew was a mover and a shaker or someone
who could make a big difference in my
career and you reach out to him for an
introduction and you might get you will
get rejected or no answer a thousand
times but all you need is that
if you can get one person to get you
back and you can pitch your ideas to
them you might just catch them on that
day and that has worked for me again and
again and again
now it's buried within years I'm not
hearing anything but that's where it was
I didn't have CEA representing me I
didn't have zero gravity or some of
these big management companies I just
had me and most filmmakers who were
working their way up just have
themselves so you have to put yourself
out there you got to put your material
out there and with my screenplays I
started putting them into all the most
prestigious screenwriting contests I
could find only the most prestigious
because that's really the only ones that
agencies and people are looking out for
and if you finished in the top three or
the top five nothing below that usually
for the top three or top five you'll get
a call from these people so anyways you
can you could there's a number of ways
to get your scripts out there to
producers or whatever just got to find
it when you were driving to meet this
person from this Craigslist post what's
going through your mind um you know I
wasn't nervous I wasn't excited I've
been in the business long enough to be
very even keel whether I get news that
would be considered a blow or whether
it's news that would be considered
life-changing I always take it even keel
because you know anything could happen
in this town and usually if it's really
good it comes down to earth a little bit
if it's really bad it's not ever that
bad I mean so when I was on the way to
meet this guy I had so many meetings
with past producers on different
projects and I'd had so many of my
scripts optioned that it wasn't I it
just wasn't a big deal to me I went
there prepared for however it might go
he liked the script I'll have a meeting
with him see if he's a nice guy he'll
say yes I'll say no I'll move on to the
next one you do it enough time over so
many years you know it it kind of ceases
to affect you it ceases to affect me as
much and I think part of that is a
defense mechanism because if you're
living and dying by the rejection or the
success of each project that's a hard
way to live life because in the film
business you're going to be rejected for
years I don't care how famous you are
and you'll have some successes too
enjoy them you know grieve philosoph if
you have but I mean I you know you got
to kind of you know keep your head on
your shoulders so then once you realize
that this person was legit and they
really did want to option your script
what were the steps they drew up a
contract and they presented it to you
yeah it was a couple years ago with this
particular producer was less formal than
most with many deals I've done since
then you've got legal teams involved
very comprehensive contracts there's
various protocols and steps that they
take with this guy fun-loving guy nicest
guy he's like okay I'll type up
something you want to do it I want to do
it here's one here's your signature
here's my signature that's good now move
on and it was it was a short form
agreement was basically what it was and
the longer form agreement came later on
once the production company had had
technically options slash purchased the
script more contracts were signed but at
first it was varied from one and a lot
of these I've learned a lot of these
producers and filmmakers who kind of
live within this million dollar in under
budget world it's it tends to be very
informal sometimes a little bit more
than I would like I would like to kind
of cover the bases a little bit more but
by and large you're not talking about
millions and millions of dollars these
are people who just want to make a movie
and many times in the past that was me
so I said okay fine this is fine you
know if I get screwed on this I'm not
gonna get screwed by much and I get a
movie under the belt so and but to my
recollection was a very simple agreement
based largely on on you know in good
faith we do this and we promise to do
this and we'll talk later and I don't
recall the exact amount of days anymore
but it just compared to my past
experiences where it's like all option
it for a year you hear nothing for a
year just nothing ever really happens
this was just like I've got this guy
know I'll give it to him he knows these
guys who are looking for this material
they're kind of a start-up and they're
really doing a lot of pictures right now
and went to them I had one meeting with
them
I I mean the money was there within days
Wow
and it was jumping straight into
pre-production it was a very very fast
production so it was you know
head-spinning ly fast but you know it
was it was in all those new experiences
are always good experiences to me I've
found that in especially in the feature
world as you encounter different people
and different deals and each feature is
always a different organism unto itself
both in terms of the personnel and the
contracts and all the variables involved
that both the good and bad experiences
are beneficial to you because you learn
from both of them so it was an
interesting process so with the bad
are there certain red flags that when
you let's say go to a meeting with
someone and you you keep an even keel
and you're driving there and you're like
okay
it could happen maybe not yes but then
somebody says something something
happens and you go BAM this is okay you
know I'm certainly not special a lot of
filmmakers have been around for a long
time but I was going I know I've been
saying I've been doing this long enough
time that I have a good instinct for all
that stuff the red flags are usually
very obvious and very fast and very
early on so you have a decision at that
point to make is it worth it some of
these flags to continue onward or not
and and as I've built my currency in my
leverage and and the kind of people I
want to work with them the kind of
projects I want to do more and more and
more I will avoid working with those
types of people are getting involved in
certain types of productions and I have
years ago I may not have done it but
certainly in the last couple years I've
turned down several projects I've turned
down offers to write movies feature
movies I've turned down directing jobs
I've turned down option agreements
because I want you know what I spotted
the red flags I want no part of it sorry
what are some of the red just maybe just
a handful like well it's hard to really
get into it some of them are so specific
I'd rather not you know just some of
them could be as simple as personality
the type of people you want to work with
how
ruling it's gonna make the experience I
think for most for me when I want to get
involved in a feature production which
is kind of like going to war you're
getting it deeply involved in this stuff
being on sets a pressure cooker you know
time and money is on the line all the
time you wanna I want to work with
people that I have a positive synergy
with we all have a singular vision of
what we want this film or that project
to be this isn't to say that you have to
get along with everybody but there are
certain personality types and certain
procedures I've seen put in place that
you know just make things harder than
they need to be some of its crossed into
legal issues some of it is just simply
you know I just don't want to work for a
bully but I can yeah the issues can be
large or small but whatever it is you
know it's it's something that you can
only attain to experience you know you
you start to just pick up on it like
anything else in life you just get a gut
reaction and and again most of these
guys in most of these deals the flags
are are numerous obvious and
demonstrated early you take a minute
early like first meeting usually you'll
know okay I've see some things here and
now I have my decision to make delay
grind through do I make it work or do I
detour off the left and take the next
project but you know it for everyone
watching I mean they able as they start
to get into more and more deals
especially feature deals you know you'll
you'll pick it up I mean most of its its
most of it's in plain sight well aside
from someone maybe being a social
bullier or just an abrasive personality
or whatever are there other things like
you know I like hey how about it's a
it's a handshake sure they don't want to
put anything in an email they only want
to call you yeah they don't want
anything and right like we're putting
words about them no no that's just
totally fine short having people who are
working with a team you trust is
important working with a team that
you're calm
with and your cohesive wave it's
difficult to be on a production some
filmmakers white might sign onto a
feature deal because I just want to get
a feature made and they sign on with a
team that maybe wasn't the best fit for
their script they have a different
vision than you now you're like this the
whole production and usually at the end
you get a picture that's muddied if
there is no singular vision now it's a
mash of both so you should always know
who you're going into business with get
a fill form that's what those meetings
are for figure out who you're
comfortable with and who you're not
comfortable in a lot of the time it's
also not the kind of flags that are
raised once you're deep into production
it's like the first caller to for
instance you'd ask for examples for me
very quickly now I'll know a producer
who's going to waste my time for six
months and never get anything done
mind you a lot of these guys are totally
decent people not a malicious bone in
their body but I know enough now that
when I hear certain things or I see the
way they do certain things and what
their planners are lack thereof for
their production in terms of getting
financing or putting together a pitch
deck and where they're gonna do their
business so on and so forth I know this
person is never going to get this
picture made they'll try but they're
never gonna get it made so you know and
again it's hard to explain how you pick
that up it's fairly basic stuff but for
me I just kind of figured it out a long
time ago so I try to work with people
where I go this guy is serious business
he knows what he's doing
I've heard his plan it's sound this is a
man with experience or woman this is
someone who has their saying all the
right things I know exactly what they're
talking about I visualize what their
business proposal is they do everything
legit none of its lazy or incomplete or
rushed you know simple little things
like that but I try my best to work with
people who I'm confident have the
ability to actually get my scripts made
otherwise I won't do this otherwise I'll
turn down the option offer I guess if
you will and that's the most important
step the second of course is sure I'd
love them to be people that we have a
good
Sergi together we can talk about the
project and move forward in a way that's
not only healthy for the relationship
and leads to more features down the line
more collaborations but also is in the
best interest of the script itself
because you never want to sign on to one
of these things and see this script that
you bled for to kind of create and bring
it to life kind of turn into this kind
of flat you know haphazard completed
project but you're just like I don't
even want my friends to see it like I
don't want anyone to see it I luckily
haven't had anything that severe but but
I can see how it can get there very
quickly if you're not careful so I guess
the lesson would be especially early on
yes you need to get a feature under your
belt and sometimes you might have to
sacrifice a little bit to get it done
but you know don't throw all your eggs
in one basket just to get your project
made make sure it's made with the right
people find the right people people that
you're comfortable with and you know go
for that it's perfectly fine to pass on
a few potential parties and and find the
right fit with a scape room you wrote
the script did you also pitch yourself
as being the director or it was that
something that came later right off the
bat I always knew I wanted to write
direct I'd done that with all my short
films but directing in the feature world
is very tricky investors like their pool
of people unless you have a theatrical e
distributed feature under your belt and
the main talent they're usually not
going to get on their list even if
you've done amazing shorts that's just
not going to happen
I won't say that's every investor out
there but just in my experience I've had
people say hey we love your reels we
love your short films it's not going to
happen I hope you understand it when I
go it's your money of course I
understand I mean you need to work with
people they you're confident can handle
a featuring with that anyways so I knew
I needed to put myself in a position
where I had some leverage if I was ever
gonna direct one of my own scripts will
say so escape room comes around and the
guys love the script and one of the
producers says I want to direct it and I
said no deal I said I directed or it's
No Deal
I gambled and I was willing to gamble
just like gambling with money in Vegas
you know if it's money that you can
afford to lose then gambling
you know same thing with the film I was
willing to lose the deal over it it
wasn't a bluff because I knew that was
my best shot in years to actually direct
a feature and if I pass it up and just
sold them the script I'm back at playing
the game I've been playing for years is
trying to get myself in a position to do
it again so I gamble I said it's me or
it's a no-go and he kind of looked down
at the table for a minute and then he
looked back up he goes okay I said great
so he of course had to take me to be
eventually what would be the production
company and the sales agents in one and
they had to sign off from me also but I
had one meeting with them and I've been
doing shorts for years so I I knew what
I was talking about I didn't go I wasn't
trying to bluff my way into directing a
feature I knew it was of a scale that I
could handle I wasn't in over my head
answered all their questions and was
confident all the things you should be
in a business meeting and after one
fairly brief meeting the the agreement
was made in we were off we're ready to
go
and that's the same not every script I
write I would make the same gamble or
make the same move some of my scripts
aren't passion projects I'm just writing
them to be sold but I do have some that
I would say the same thing again and I
wouldn't be bluffing it's me or I'll
keep it on the shelf so not everyone
will be forced to be in that position
but you know that's where you get into
the situation where I want to direct
this I'll max out my credit cards they
won't give it to me I'm just gonna do it
myself
so I luckily I didn't have to go down
that route but anyways I engineered a
situation where I could not force my way
in but use what little leverage I had to
my advantage and luckily append out and
where was the film shot weren't you film
it by and large it was shot in Burbank
local great we had a a good portion of
the film I wanted to write something
that could be done relatively
inexpensive so a good portion of the
film is inside an escape room
and so they built one on a stage in this
building they built it in a camera house
that was still open for business it was
a camera rental house as what it was we
had a little stage and we shot some
scenes and Skeet Ulrich and all these
guys and the hallways out there also in
a building that was open for business so
people would be leaving their office and
walked through the shot it was
incredible I was just like I wasn't
prepared for that you just roll with it
what are you gonna do but it was this
building right next to the Burbank
Airport so we had planes flying overhead
all the time for winning our shots oh we
could deal with that also and then we
had some desert shots that were shot out
in Lancaster and some other various
locations but by and large it was local
because it was all designed to be I
wanted to write something that was just
there
relatively speaking was just the easiest
thing to produce what's the most
attractive thing I can make for
investors this is something that can be
shot real quick for very little money
high-concept good hook why wouldn't we
produce it I was just trying to give him
everything you could give them and
reduce the amount of you know nose that
they can possibly come up with that's
pretty cool see it's just like these
green lights that just happen with
probably you know yeah and it's I didn't
know what would happen after that I was
like mom Here I am I've been working my
whole life I've got a movie playing in
theaters I was like this is just that's
great and I was like you know it's a
small movie so I don't know what
attention I'm gonna get but as I
mentioned before it no agency called no
management company called it I did get
pressed but not like Hollywood Reporter
like it didn't really do it dude that
much for me so I I didn't know what to
expect as I said the fight never ends so
I've got some a bunch of feature deals
that are pending right now they're in
pre-production they're in development
ones locking up distribution not a one
of them stemming from escape room those
were other deals that I've just kept up
the fight kept out there going just
grinding away you know so it's it's an
it's an interesting profession we've
we've chosen you never know what you're
going to get again as I said I'm even
keel about it
I'm always working on new projects and
I'll never stop and I'm not surprised
that escape room didn't open up the
floodgates for me and I'm actually okay
with it you just kind of keep going
every day you keep going and I've been
doing it for so many years now that it's
all I know but all the more reasons for
beginner directors and beginner writers
to prepare themselves for that like the
fight kind of is endless it's kind of
forever and I think for most of us for
me the fight is part of what we love
about the business because not all of us
can do what it is that we do it's to me
it's a kind of a privilege to be able to
say that not only do you survive the
business but you thrive in it so that's
you kind of grab grasp onto the positive
aspects of it just keep going looking
back on it now what were the drawbacks
and the benefits to making so many
shorts and do you do you think it was
worth it I know you want to make a
feature much sooner yeah I would say
that for me personally it's worked out
just fine I've taken in an unusual path
I've taken a very patient path I wanted
to prepare myself as much as possible
with all my short films as I'd mentioned
before and I did that so I didn't want
to get into the director's chair for a
feature and below it it's hard enough to
get that first chance I didn't want to
get there and blow it and never get
another chance so for me it worked out
nicely but it took 15 years 15 odd years
whatever was 10 years whereas other
people go this and I'm gonna go for it
from the beginning and again some of
them make it early and since they're
younger than me I mean you know agencies
love hot up-and-coming talent so if
you're young mid-20s and you make
something really cool you're gonna get
more attention than if I make something
cool it's just kind of the way the
business at least the industry on here
is just kind of set up so I can't say
the way I did it is right or wrong or or
or whatnot you know I've always been a
patient guy I've always taken my own
road to things so you know I think it's
been beneficial to me obviously the
drawbacks are
40 and only have what will soon be two
features under my belt and if I'd taken
a slightly different path maybe I'd have
ten at this point you know but that's a
drawback I'm willing to live with I
think I did it the only way that it was
ever gonna work for me you know and it's
an interesting question because if you
ask 10 other filmmakers what they think
of my strategy they might laugh their
heads off for all I know I don't know
but it's just it's a weird business
everyone's on their own you were totally
on you can read as many books on the
subject as you want the reality is is no
one's gonna give you anything you've got
to go out there and earn it through
talent and hard work perseverance and
all those kind of things in every single
filmmaker myself included every single
filmmaker ever met literally has their
own fascinating story as to how they got
it done how they got noticed and some of
them might be more successful than
others in terms of how far they've risen
and what level of movies they're doing
now but all of them just literally found
their way through the labyrinthian
maze that is Hollywood and have made it
wherever they are these days can you
recommend any resources for a young
filmmaker starting out I know you said
everybody has their own paths are there
some resources that have been really
valuable for you
in terms of DIY sort of not just not
learning about film theory or whatever
no sure sure no I understand I listen
I'm sure there's a million books on the
subject and I read many in college that
were perfectly fine literally in terms
of people from a nuts-and-bolts
standpoint you know what do I do
how do i how do I start directing at all
or whatever I would recommend just
getting on set get on as a PA get on
whatever you can get done a lot of sense
figure out how a set works you don't
have to become an expert at it you don't
have to spend five years on the set but
get on the set figure it out figure it
out
the world that you're going to be living
in and leading at some point as
certainly as a director know that world
and that is the very seedling to you
starting to put together your own world
I would recommend
working it places that will teach you
what you need to know if you're not on
set go work at a camera rental house
learn the gear if you want to get into
writing and producing work at an agency
work at a management company work at a
production company you know I would
learn who's in your business who do you
want to know there's a lot of assistance
out there figure out who works for who
network in terms of gear become an
expert at it you don't have to become
you know someone who's paid $1,000 a day
to run the gear but no one from a
general standpoint know what you need
know what you don't need
if you're writing I would say one of the
best steps you can do is is read great
screenplays they're all online these
days anyhow read The Godfather read
whatever you can read new scripts old
scripts read read read read and then
read some more figure out what made them
great then start writing yourself and
write and write and write probably going
to be pretty awful at first it'll get
better until you start to find your own
voice and you know that's what you do
whether you're learning the gear and
pulling it together to start tackling
producing and directing your own short
film or whether you're writing your own
scripts don't be intimidated by it don't
be scared by it you just do it and then
you do it again and then you do it again
and again and again and keep honing it
until you learn what you need to and I
think both will learn along the way more
so than most books can tell you to learn
through experience you say that horror
sparks conversation I think a great
story sparks conversation I think horror
can spark certain visceral reactions
yeah I I I think a great film my dream
is a filmmaker is have one of my scripts
or one of my films cause an audience
audience to want to leave the theater
and go and talk about it and debate
about it and think about it I don't
necessarily want to make the type of
movie that they eat their popcorn they
walk away by the time they get to the
car they don't remember what they just
saw some fun movie whatever I think any
great story or included
something that will make people talk and
and I mentioned privilege before I I do
think it's a privilege to be in a
position where I can build stories and
characters and tell stories that I think
aim to make you see the world and your
place in it for maybe a different
perspective I think that's a very
powerful thing that we do and have the
ability to do and I aspire to do it even
better than I than I do so now but yeah
and short I think any great film should
spark discussion I think that's the goal
I think you should be something that
inspires you or traumatizes you were
scares you know whatever reaction is the
point of your story I think that should
always be the point to get a reaction
otherwise your films just putting people
to sleep you know so at least that so
that's that's what that's what I aim for
how did you learn how to write a
feature-length script yeah I never went
to any master programs I never went to
any film programs that specifically
taught me my craft as I'd mentioned see
you was more about film theory and
various things like that it didn't
really teach me in great depth what you
need to do as a director or writer I had
to learn all that on my own whether I
did it right or wrong who's to say but
for me is that at looted too before I
just wrote and wrote and wrote and wrote
and through all that writing through all
those years you start to find your own
voice and when I wasn't writing I was
reading again great scripts different
kinds of scripts the more type of
scripts the better any different styles
you know you never want to get attached
to one person's style that you might
start to emulate it I mean read
different styles and go gosh this is
amazing I never thought you could do it
this way and what I eventually earned
learned through the years is is when I'm
writing my scripts I don't just want to
write a scene or write a story I bring
literally the words the structure of the
sentences themselves to life I break
things apart certain descriptions
certain ways I do it depending on the
project it should be an experience to
read it and it should be some
that literally pulls the reader from one
page to the next where they can't stop
if your script doesn't hook the reader
on the first page you're done that's
just the realities is a lot of agents
and managers will joke well I'll give
you the old five page rule there was the
rule of thumb some say ten but that
means I'll read the first five pages and
if it doesn't have me I don't read the
rest because these guys are reading
hundreds of scripts a week they don't
got time and they've got a good radar
they know it gets it in my personal
opinion I think they gave it half a page
or page if your script just isn't really
good both from a grammatical structural
story standpoint whatever it is
immediately you're not going to gain any
traction with them so that's the goal as
a writer as you keep writing and when I
was teaching myself to write I aspired
to get to that point I want to pull them
in from the first sentence and never let
them go and how to achieve that in a
variety of different genres and you know
whatever your story's about was a
challenge and you just keep working on
it until you get it did you read any
books or screenwriting books or no it
was just all scripts and watch movies
okay yeah yeah and I that's a good point
you just made watch and watch a lot of
movies watch some good movies you can
learn a lot from that what some people
will do because you know writing is
seeming a lot of dialogue can be tricky
because once you film it you go boy this
is so I just went to Talking Heads this
is so dialogue heavy watch a great scene
between two characters talking in a
movie and then write it down most of the
time not all the time well there in
store it might be a different choice or
a different circumstance but with most
writers once you write down the
dialogues and when your favorite movies
you'll see it's a lot shorter than you
think these guys know what they're doing
they know how to write something that
that doesn't turn into a five page
monologue watch a lot of movies watch
them and learn from them and then again
keep reading reading lots of different
screenplays obviously I'm sure there's
some invaluable books out there you
could read and obviously there's master
programs you can go out there and get a
masters in screenwriting and for all I
know you can write
pants off of me after going there for a
year but there's certainly those types
of things are available to anyone at any
time I never had the time or money for
it so I did it you could say the hard
way but you know for me it was just I
guess I learned through my directing and
producing that experience breeds
experience and that's what pushed me
forward so it was the same with my
riding I wasn't reading books I was just
writing and what reading I was doing was
other people's work what's working for
them what are they doing that I'm not
doing in my scripts and I would never
try to emulate their voice because every
great script writer you can read it you
can almost go I know who wrote this
would never try to emulate that but I
would just from a broad stroke
standpoint look and go what are they
doing that's so great you know you
obviously the best-cooked screenplays
I've ever read as I'm reading it I
visualized the movie I don't even think
about the writing it just pulls you in
to such a degree that before you know it
you've gone through it and you've been
perfectly visualizing the film and you
don't feel yourself turning the pages
you don't feel yourself reading the
paragraphs how do I get to that point so
I would read these guys and read them
and read them and just try to make my
own writing better and I'm still doing
that to this day always trying to push
myself to me better can't you see him is
it Nosferatu Bela Lugosi it was like oh
the original yeah it's a corpse there's
no dialogue right oh yeah oh there is
okay no no I'm saying which I love by
the way no dialogue in fact that was
another challenge I gave myself back
when I was doing shorts I did short with
no dialogue can I tell a great story
without a single word I love things like
and in fact one of my favorite features
when I was a kid was I think was black
stallion black stallion was such a good
movie but pretty much the first half of
film is dialogue free it's a boy
and as and the horse on an island right
and it's fabulous it's so good and
there's not a word you know or if there
are it's just a couple here and there
that's still something I'm mastering
when
comes to writing because you know as the
general rule of thumb is it's a minute
per page when you're writing you write a
pages you one page of your script equals
about a minute of screen time by and
large I guess that's true but I mean if
you don't have dialogue it really can
alter things and I ran into challenges
with that with escape room because there
was certain segments that were dialogue
free a lot of action happening in inside
of this escape room and when we got to
actually shooting and I went this is
gonna be a lot shorter than I'd
originally planned
you know I don't want to have like the
nicest like 50-minute feature ever so I
had to kind of work my way around that
and kind of find some other ways to tell
the story but you know I'm a big fan of
that I'm did you know sriracha was
something you I think I watched the
first part of it and it was just very
slow and I just found it very
interesting because it was creepy and it
was scary yeah but but just yeah the the
the slow the pacing of it and yeah it's
not everyone's cup of tea sure you know
listen it sometimes the slow burn is a
little bit too slow there's another old
film by I think it was Carl Theodor
Dreyer around the same time as Nosferatu
I believe 1932 1919 31 is called the
vampire that one you should check out
same thing all that was fear amazing
experimental photography of these kind
of foreboding shadow figures right yeah
didn't have special effects it was all
practical but it was very clever and it
was just a very different take the
Nosferatu but very interesting not
everyone's cup of tea I showed it to a
group of friends once and they all split
it was me watching the phone but but it
still a worthy experience at the other
time does a horror screenplay have its
own structure to me regardless of genre
they're all gonna have this you know
whatever structure you want to give it
every film I've told if you want to
break structure you can I think as long
as you know the rules you can break the
rules so there's times where I've
written screenplays that are broken into
three acts there's times where I've
written screenplays that are broken down
into between six and eight key plot
points
and those to date for me have crossed
all genres not horse Pacific so no I
wouldn't say that horror has its own
structure I mean but one of the great
things about writing is there's again I
think if you know the rules you can
break the rules is I've seen scripts
that break the usual 3x structure and
they don't follow the usual beats and
they're amazing I wish they could get
made they are just some of them are just
gosh I don't want to say meandering has
a negative connotation but they just are
flowing along on their own trajectory
and you don't know where it's gonna go
because you're you I think most people
are trained at the usual pacing
certainly with Hollywood films they
follow certain act certain key points
there's a certain flow to it that a lot
of most of our big hit movies if you
break them down you go my god it's
almost in the page they follow these
formulas some of these scripts that I've
read don't do that not all of them are
great but the ones I have read that are
great the very brave in this sense they
went I'm just gonna write what I'm gonna
write and you can like or not but very
clever very very clever no discernible
break between X and no discernible
structure in the way you usually would
think about it but very clever stuff
then is there any parts of writing or
that differs in terms of the actual you
know dynamics of screenwriting yeah I
mean I get it you're trying to have a
scare I kill something every so often
but other than that no I mean again each
writer has to attack each project you
know depending on what the needs of that
story are but in my experience
structures of structure or stories of
story it can be dramatic it can be scary
it can be funny but you're kind of
following the same rules to tell a
classic story you know and at the end of
the day I don't remember them all
anymore but someone had mentioned that
there's you know you basically have only
three or four primary stories that we
ever tell this love story and so on and
so forth not very many we dress them up
differently and we created these
different genres but the story's pretty
much were all
used to the same basic structure how do
you create an awesome horror protagonist
how do you create an awesome or
protagonist antagonist or protagonist uh
both both I said protagonist bullets do
both I think it just comes down to for
me in particular what core films
inspired you the most and for me I have
certain ones that were important to me
or influenced me certain horror
directors that influenced me more so
than others certain life experiences I
think certain real-life fears I think
for me I take the DNA contained with all
of them and I try to put it into a
memorable but memorable character I
think I don't really want to do a
character that we've seen a million
times before if I can help it I want to
make someone where you truly don't know
what's gonna happen next or you feel the
stakes are heightened
one of the tropes and one of the
consequences of of following the similar
structure I went to writing screenplays
it's the audience kind of by this point
knows where it's going most the time
they've seen everything it's hard to
really fool them so whenever I'm putting
together a story and whenever I'm coming
up with characters whether it's a
protagonist and certainly an antagonist
is I want to do someone who if it's a
horror piece someone who scares me and
you know where that comes from just
depends on what the story is but I want
him to be memorable I want him to be
unique and to stand out I think it'd be
fun if one day if I ever did that type
of story I made one of those guys she
becomes like Connick why not have it be
the next penny wise you know you've seen
these these fun posters they'll do where
all the bad guys are in a movie theater
I want one of my guys to be there you
know put them in that group someone that
kind of just stands out just like the
filmmaker themself has to find a way to
stand out from the crowd
I'd love to come up with a character
that you know people remember and kind
of stands the test of time I think
that's the goal well I mean do you think
that
the person has to be real likable is to
stake carry and I know I use that a lot
but I found Kerry to be a very likable
character I know sure maybe people do
but and I found that the the antagonist
in the film to be very unlikable yeah I
I think as always each stories organic
and the characters have to be true to
what the story is I am attracted to I
think good guys that aren't squeaky
clean and bad guys that aren't
vaudeville bad twirling their moustaches
I like to muddy it up I like gray
characters I think that's something that
people can relate to a lot if you see a
bad guy that at times I wouldn't say you
empathize with but you can understand a
little bit definitely not a James Bond
villain this is someone who is more
relatable and in that sense can be more
scary
it could be someone you know or someone
that you can believe running into some
day and the same thing with a good guy
I'm far more interested in a protagonist
who I can relate to and most people you
know they're not perfect
they've got flaws and maybe they've had
some things in the past that they regret
I wouldn't go as far as to say they have
you know big sins hiding in their closet
but you know they have imperfections and
maybe they've done things they're not
proud of I think that makes for a far
more interesting character now again
since I've mentioned James Bond for
doing James Bond people want James Bond
villain they want they want a little bit
of the vaudeville in there and that's
fine and for Kerry you'd mentioned I
mean Kerry she had to be likable she I
think and they got Spacek was
amazing in it you kind of had to feel
she was literally a real girl in high
school who was kind of a loner in the
outsider and that's the way that
character had to work and her mother was
terrifying it's you had to be you know
and I I don't think making that mother
and pathetic would have worked in that
story so the kind of great character I'm
talking about you know comes down to the
appropriate story that it's used for so
but for me though those are the kind of
characters that attract me good or bad
and and
generally when I'm coming up with a
story I look for ways to really kind of
flesh them out in that manner and then
you had the Betty Buckley character who
to some could have seen like the bad guy
but she was you know very altruistic to
carry yeah and was almost like prodding
her and like this tough love and I
thought that was a great thing because
she didn't have that she had all these
different forces yeah listen I think
whether you're making someone who's a
little bit muddy or they're just full-on
dead or full-on good I think the goal
should be to make these characters you
know three-dimensional you should almost
be able to feel their motivations just
by watching their face or their actions
or what they're doing in the scene not
necessarily only with dialogue and and
you know from any writing standpoint
that's what you're always aiming for no
one really ever I think sets out to
write what they call it kind of a
cardboard you know or the carbon copy
you know character is someone who feels
very two or one-dimensional and very
flat and we're kind of saying would you
expect them to say no writer sets out to
do that on purpose I think but you know
it's a tricky thing to really flesh
characters out on the page you know I'm
sure when they wrote you know Carrie
they didn't have Spacek bare to
flush you down they didn't have her
there to bring it to life someone
originally had to bring that character
to life on the page it's a hard thing to
do and I think it's something that
writers must demand themselves to really
aspire to and work on I'm really trying
to get theirs
as best they can and am i there yet I
don't know but I try to be and going
forward as always and everything I do
always trying to push it to the next
level just get a little bit better hone
your craft and keep going further and
further I think I'll do that until I die
I don't think I don't know any filmmaker
who feel or writer who feels they've
finally got it they finally got it you
know at some point I think they're all
even the best of the best I imagine are
still honing their craft well with the
Nightmare on Elm Street series or you
know it seemed like the the protagonists
would change but the antagonist was
always the same and so am I correct in
that it's been yeah
first film for the well there are a few
other many yeah so I'm just trying to
remember correctly so it seemed like the
the protagonist always changed but the
antagonist was always the same yeah you
need more people to kill I guess so yeah
okay alright and and then you put in the
music - so we're like this fun sort of
almost party feel to a lot of it but
then you knew something franchises are
tricky and I give people a lot of credit
for trying to take him on this is had
you mention Nightmare on Elm Street
because yeah I remember was thinking
that when I watched about a year ago the
original film it's a scary movie it's a
really scary movie and I had forgotten
how popular was it went on to span five
or six films or whatever was but it
became so popular and this happens a lot
of horror franchises that the original
antagonist becomes part of the you know
pop culture zeitgeist he eventually
became the comic relief in his own
movies whenever a Freddy was in the
scene he was giving all the funny lines
and very straight and then they took a
break for a few years and they made the
new nightmare where they made him scary
again but they needed that break he was
like a different character still Freddy
Krueger but he was he looked a little
different he's very dark or whatever
it's uh it's it yeah but that's
Hollywood and writing a franchise is
just another complication I'm sure as a
writer to come in you just kind of have
to go the flow and make it work but I do
remember that I do remember there being
a drastic change along the you know life
on that storyline and you're right it
was one antagonist always wanted tagging
eyes and the protagonists would come and
go and survive or not not survive you
know yeah I enjoyed it how does that
filmmakers be proactive this business
and not be passive
I'm glad you asked I've always been
proactive I learned a long time ago to
take your own initiative don't wait for
anyone to give you anything go out there
and
make job opportunities I've learned that
if you're not moving forward in this
business you're moving backward you have
to stay on it after all these years and
I bet features going on everything I
still everyday literally just about
every day I'm doing something that
further that new ideas new concepts new
networking new contacts whatever
whatever it is every day I have to stay
on it in terms of how to stay proactive
whatever it is if you're a writer keep
writing keep pitching and keep entering
more festivals enter your scripts into
coverage learn from the notes that you
get from these people I mean just stay
on your craft directing is the same
thing doing short films keep working on
your demo reel keep working to get your
features together it's a lot of it
sometimes crosses over keep going to
market go to AFM pitch new material go
to whatever festivals or markets you can
afford I mean you know whatever is your
specialty whether it's writing or
directing stay on it every day I have
kids I'm a very busy guy I find the time
even if it's late at night the last
couple of scripts that I've written that
I sold I literally wrote overnight
that's the only time I have so you do
what you got to do overnight Oh
overnight and and I've been doing that
for years and and it's fine it's not a
big deal but the point is is you just do
what you gotta do you stay proactive if
I'm not writing I'm reaching out to
people I spoke with three high-level
executives today responded to my
introduction it's just what you do I
think certainly in this business it's
all too easy to go I'm tired I just
don't want to this week I've got two
side jobs you know I'm just tired I'll
get to my script next week that week
becomes a month that becomes a year
pretty soon you're like I've been out
here and made the move to this really
expensive beautiful very expensive city
I don't really do anything
don't worry inton happens to a lot of
people you have to will yourself to do
it and obviously you should love doing
it also but just like anything else it
can be hard work may not be in the mood
to do film stuff every day sometimes I'm
not but if it's not every day you should
continually feel yourself being pushed
along you know be one of them be that
guy who like throws the pencils of the
ceilings that when you look up there's
no that says keep working you should be
working like no kind of thing like stay
on it it's just like anything else when
you wrote escape Rubin before you sold
it were you in a place where you're like
this train isn't moving fast enough that
I need to do something or we're so
driven because of like going to escape
room and then you're like okay let me
try to write one for them I don't wasn't
any panicked situation over the years I
quietly resign myself to at least the
possibility that I'll never get a
feature made I had so many of my scripts
option but not financed that I was like
okay I might just be making my short
films for dream seekers forever and I
came to peace with it I was like as long
as I get to tell stories and produce
films and direct films I'll be okay it
doesn't mean I gave up on trying to to
achieve my goals but I came to peace
with it but certainly I think is I
started to get older I said I gotta make
some moves here I mean I can't just keep
doing what I've been doing I got to do
something and I got to make it happen so
I kind of gave myself a deadline I said
I'm getting the future done this year
not necessarily directing if I'm gonna
sell a script of a right sold script
this year and I shifted up my strategy
my strategy became what do they want I
can't just write for me what do they
want then I pretty much had an idea
through enough meetings but what I
didn't know I just looked up you know
again just keep your finger on the pulse
of what producers are asking for we like
your stuff but what we're looking for
this year is IP driven content or
whatever it is and I've been in enough
meetings where in this case horror they
said this is what we want you know and
if you don't have access to those
produce
look at all the hit movies what do they
all have a comfortable you know you find
the common denominators and do what you
got to do for me that's what I do I said
this script may not be like genre
redefining it may not be the script on
most probably I put a lot of myself in
it I made a story that I'm happy with
but this is definitely not a passion
project
I wrote this to be sold this is a
business decision and I wrote it and I
sold and I learned from that not
necessarily that I'm gonna throw all my
chips in that basket this is just
business now because it's film I love it
and it's a passion to me and it's
creative fulfilling so I'm not just in
different business what it has taught me
though is to stay proactive as always
but to walk that line you know you can
always if you're a millionaire you'll
make your own passion projects and do it
however you want but if you want to go
out and get other people's money you got
to give them a little of what they're
looking for so the challenge becomes to
tell really cool creative interesting
stories within a framework that's gonna
work for other people and I think that's
a big place to start it was a place for
me let's see where it takes me you had
talked about writing overnight I was
wondering if you could just take me
through that process like what's it like
when do you start
is it like midnight and where are you
and are you playing music and what are
you doing to get yourself in that
headspace and why'd you stop I learned a
long time ago to write wherever and
whenever I could sometimes there's music
on movie soundtracks or whatever type of
story I'm writing to kind of get me
going sometimes the kids are sleeping
music goes off I got to write in silence
sometimes it's sitting in a car
sometimes it's at the airport it's
wherever I can not everyone's in my boat
with me I've got a busy family life
which I love to death but in terms of my
writing it's it would often be when the
kids are asleep and I've gotten house
chores done I'm trained so sometimes it
sounds great yeah you know so there you
are it's like I've worked all day yeah I
come home I handle the kids and
and there's family time and you play
with your kids make sure to give them
the time they need and before you know
what is ten o'clock and you're exhausted
you gotta get up at 6 a.m. the next
morning but you got to do your thumb
stuff you got to stay proactive as we
said so it might be 10 11 o'clock you
sit down and you start writing you find
a quiet corner right I have a office at
home that I work from that has become my
daughter's room so now I write kind of
anywhere else I can the kitchen table
but yeah you know sometimes I'll have
music if I'm lucky all the times I'll
keep it quiet or just a little solitary
lamp and you sit there you know in a
perfect world I have all the stuff I
needed seven nowhere to put it right now
I've got my movie posters from the child
from my childhood I've got like I've got
a necklace with the what is it the Oran
from neverending story
I've got all these things that inspire
me you know pirate stuff an Indiana
Jones stuff and Lord knows what all
ready to go up in an office so I can sit
in the midst of it and just be purely
inspired and just go right now I I don't
have room for it so I basically sit in
you know my kitchen with like my blank
like beige walls and I just nothing
inspiring there whatsoever and I just
got to rely on what's in here I'll let
the inspiration bubble up from inside
and it's fine you know you go to bed at
2:00 or 3:00 in the morning it's not
gonna kill you let me know as they say
I'll sleep when I'm dead I guess you
know but you know and the goal
ultimately I think just like with any
filmmaker is when I have some of my
projects coming up that I'm hoping or
game-changers it becomes something I can
do full-time and then I write during the
day and I can sleep at night but until
then you know this is just this is just
what you do but I've been doing it for
years and I adapted to it a long time
ago yeah you just have me thinking about
what you said how you had quote resigned
yourself to being okay with just making
movies even if it wasn't shortened short
movies right or even if it wasn't
quote-unquote like making it you were
fine doing that and that's really
interesting because some people might be
so hurt or upset that they would just be
like no forget it I'm leaving and and or
I'm doing something else just yes yeah
this is what I eluded
- before I think it comes down to would
you do this for free the rest your life
would you do this knowing that you're
gonna have to work a job or two on the
side or frankly those will be your
primary jobs your films will be on the
side would you you know give up this and
that to make films that you know maybe
will be seen in festivals will never
have a budget more than $500 or $1,000
and and for me the answer was always yes
I just love making movies I've been
doing it since I was a kid I'll do it
until I die and yeah I came to a point
where I was like if I never get a
feature made it won't be for lack of
trying but it's not gonna kill me
I have all these movies coming together
through dream seekers I enjoy it people
are seeming to enjoy it you know if
that's what it's going to be if that's
gonna be the height of where my career
goes so be and I was fully prepared for
that because with all these people out
here again the odds of breaking through
are astronomically against you it just
is what it is
so I was like you know I can't just
expect it to happen and I've had all
these deals fall through I mean it's
been years I'm like 34 years old at this
point so you know I came to peace with
it and then you know escape room just
kind of happened
when I happened but escaped room again
happened on Craigslist that I just hit
the guy when he happened to be online I
mean it easily could none that could
have been passed over I could be sitting
on a scape room the script today right
someone could have been asking for your
routing number what's your checking all
sorts of things yeah I mean that's the
thing Craigslist is either fantastic or
you got some something that's like yeah
stay away yeah yeah I mean you know
listen do you want to be meeting your
film producers and setting up big deals
through Craigslist no in fact I don't
think you let it I don't think the
system works that way anymore usually I
use it as a way to find some mid-level
crew positions yeah it's a great place
which was safe enough it was fine that
was just one of those random things I
didn't know any producers I had no
agencies reaching out for me so I just
did
it kind of panned out might not pan out
again for 10 more years every other
contact I've ever made or every other
film deal I've ever made has been off
meetings based in person through
references or through more professional
more secure if you will
sites you know so but whatever takes
right I mean that's what that's what it
is I mean God knows all the different
ways you can meet people but you know
it's been an interesting ride and we'll
see what what would the next 10 to 20
brings so so there's a section on
Craigslist that's called screenwriting
or at that time this was a while back
but there was a section called
I think it was writing I think right now
okay and there's a crew section also
what sometimes I would see me not to
yeah and I get flagged very quickly and
I just put it back up again so I think
people like me are probably why they
change the system but I miss you man
I knew producers were looking they're
just they may be smaller producers but
that's okay I wasn't writing for
Paramount Studios at the time it's like
I was looking for small producers and I
knew that they were on there and you
just had to catch them at the right time
so it's great ultimately I kind of took
advantage of the system I think it was
designed to be writing the writing
section would be I think you would put
up a thing saying I'm a writer I'm
available or I'm here it is I'm looking
to hire a writer that's what that
section oh not so much for you to say
I've got a script right here if you
anyone wants to pay for it or whatever
okay so but gotta do what you got to do
that's all I'm saying I I had I had to
get my script out there so I I did what
I did but anyways I think the system's
changed now I think you have to pay for
postings and they said the other but
Craigslist come and goes it doesn't
matter now you got an Instagram you got
Facebook you got Twitter you got
LinkedIn you've got ink tip you've got
God's screen craft you've got a lot of
places mandy to go now to meet people
doesn't really matter when one goes away
there's lots of others out there but I
think the bigger picture is despite what
any of them are there's a multitude of
opportunities for writers to get their
material
there it's just a it's just gonna matter
and how much time and how much money you
have to invest in certain things because
all these writing festivals certainly
prestigious ones it might cost a
seventy-five bucks and you're going up
against at times ten eleven thousand
other submissions what are the odds
you're gonna land on the top three and
get a call from an agent not very good
but they can teach you a lot about your
skill set and where you are compared to
others and that can really help you
adjust and grow as writers so that can
be the most important thing to take out
of it but you know all just
opportunities different ways to get
there